شوف هذا مجهود الحمد لله مجهود الطاقم
التقني للمنتخب الوطني ومجهود وليد
الركراكي اولا مجهودات اللاعبين اللي
نشكرهم من هذا المنبر ومجهودات الجباره
القطر ما شاء الله على هذا التنظيم وعلى
هذا الامور هذه اللي كلها صراحه تشرف تشرف
العرب كثير والحمد لله على كل شيء والحمد
لله على فوز المغرب ودائما لفوق وديمه
المغرب نشوف شعورك اليوم كام مشجع عربي
لكره القدم والله افتخر بالفريق المغربي
[موسيقى]
بطل العالم صعبه
اذا لعب نفس الحماس وهل جمهور ترى الجمهور
يجنن منتخب اسبانيا حتى اللي بيكلم راح
ههه بصراحه كان الماتش في المستوى لانه
كان فريق في المستوى بالطبع ويعني الحمد
لله كان الفوز بجداره ماشي يعني ما فزناش
ببساطه يعني لما يكون الفوز يعني بقوه
ماشي بحال الا كان الفوز بيسهل فالحمد لله
انه مشرفونا واحنا في بلد الغربه عندنا
احساس اكثر لو كان يعني كنا في بلد في
بلدنا الام الصراحه احنا وايد مستانسين
بما ان هاي اخر دوله عربيه موجوده هنا صدق
وايد مستانسين ونحنا ندعمهم بصراحه يعني
كيف كانت الاجواء بالمدرجات اليوم فتحه
حماس جدا ما توقعته همم الجمهور والعدد
اللي وصل هذا الصراحه يعيد ويخلي لنا
العرب متحدين وان شاء الله ان شاء الله ان
شاء الله اللي عليه يا رب مين بطل
المباراه اليوم
ما اسباب برايك هذا الانجاز التاريخ اليوم
هو بطل يعني المنتخب المغربي
هو يعني جميع الدول الثانيه او الشعوب
الثانيه هم يعني بيحكون عن المغرب انه
مباراه تدريب بس بس لا عندنا اقوي هم
مسمين عليهم استاذ اطلس يعني الاطلس باسم
ومن اجداد
الشعب المغربي وهنيئا للعرب كله بوس كبير
يعني اللاعيبه اليوم كانوا في الموعد يعني
وقدموا مبارك كبيره يعني شكرا تحيه لهم
يعني اسعد الجمهور والمدرب هو رقم التقنيه
كلهم تحيه لهم وان شاء الله يعني طموحنا
ان شاء الله كبير اننا نتاهل يعني نصف
النهائي ولما للنهائي ولماذا نفوز بكاس
العالم يعني طموح بيكبر مباراه بعد مباراه
وديمه مغربي وشك
قال برازيل ايتها فرقه مرحبا نحن هنا
مبروك
[موسيقى]